okay so sonia back with morbius to bring
us more bs and this feels like the
perfect film to feature a vampire
because it sucks jared leto needs to
jared let go of his dreams of being in a
good comic book movie the film is out
now and it contains possibly the most
confusing ending since mystique picked
up wolverine at the end of days of
future past the movie has a lot to
impact from it but luckily in one of the
weirdest marketing moves ever director
daniel espinoza spoiled the whole film
before its release and it does clear up
some of the questions that you might
have i initially thought him doing this
might be in early april fools but the
movie does end the way that he said with
a character traveling across the
multiverse from the mcu into the sony
one it's the biggest downgrade since
jared leto went from the joke at a
mobius and by the end of it you'll be
hoping that blade is going to show up in
the universe too throughout this video
we're going to be breaking it all down
so hold on to your butt as we go through
it i'll try go easy on it though but
there will be heavy spoilers i did see
how empty my cinema was so i'm guessing
you're here without seeing it but yeah
just a heads up mate now make sure you
hit the thumbs up button if you have fun
and with that out of the way thanks for
clicking this now let's get into mobius
okay so mobius is a marvel legend more
like marvel legend figure the throat is
solo film we follow him as he attempts
to cure a red blood disease and he uses
a treatment that eventually turns him
into a living vampire that must feast on
flesh in order to stay alive the film
opens with him leaving a helicopter in
order to get up close and personal with
some vampire bats and from here the
movie tells his origin story through
flashbacks he attempts to also save his
childhood friend lucian who gets renamed
milo played by matt smith milo has
financed a lot of his work and he's just
as desperate to be cured as sonia to
make us think that this has anything to
do with the mcu now morbius is the
creator of a form of artificial blood
that we're told to save more lives than
penicillin and alongside his co-doctor
martine bancroft he carries out
experiments on himself the pair travel
out to international waters in order to
not get arrested for their human trials
and after injecting himself with vampire
bat dna he becomes a monster mobius
kills everyone in the bow except for
martine and though he flees before the
ship is discovered he becomes number one
suspect back home morbius tries to take
the artificial blood to quench his
thirst but the window between these
feeds becomes less and less and thus he
needs some of the red stuff milo comes
to him at this point and also asks to be
cured but after morbius rejects him he
takes matters into his own hands milo
then starts feasting on people and
mobius is blamed for the crimes he's
sent to jail and after realizing that
milo is behind it all he escapes and
decides to take him down milo kills
their childhood mentor who doesn't even
have a name in the cast list and he also
seemingly murders martine wraps up much
in the way that you'd expect with
morbius beating milo and he travels off
on the run afflicted with his condition
unable to live in society however it's
revealed that martine was also injected
with the serum and she awakens as one of
the undead the first major question that
you likely have is what universe is
morbius set in well the trailers had a
lot of people scratching their heads as
we got shots of things like ozcorp a
poster of spider-man with murderer on it
and of course adrian toomes aka the
vulture absolutely all of these scenes
and shots from the trailer don't make it
into the movie and it very much feels
like the studio are partaking in false
advertising to get us interested in the
film i know studios sometimes hide or
alter things for trailers but they don't
out and now oversell what's going to be
in the movie and it does feel quite
cheap to do this hell this is the studio
that even had people thinking doctor
strange was mephisto for a bit because
of how he was in the no way home trailer
but this feels like a definite step
above that it's left a lot of people
confused however the director has stated
that the movie does take place in the
same universe as tom hardy's venom now
that the shot of spider-man is removed
from the movie he has confirmed that
there is a version of the web slinger in
this universe but he kept tight-lipped
about it didn't mind spoiling the whole
movie did you but uh moving on now we
already know that toby maguire's
universe has its own venom in it through
toe for grace so that rules him out as
being the spider-man in this one tom
hardy went to the mcu but he returned
because he wasn't a part of that world
and thus it also rules out tom holland
all that remains is andrew garfield and
all that hype for them bringing back the
actor has turned to worry because if it
is him and yeah they really need to make
sure that that script is spider-verse
levels before they start filming don't
let them massacre my boy now the reason
that i say if it is him is because it
could also possibly be miles morales
though he hasn't been cast in live
action yet they could potentially bring
him in here however miles is often
minted by peter so they would likely
need to have him in the universe first
before introducing him fully i say that
though but yeah venom showed us that
they don't mind introducing spider-man
characters without spider-man actually
being there now the director did say
that we would learn very soon what's
happening so we might get an
announcement either over the weekend or
in the next one now the two post credits
scenes are pretty much completely
interlinked with each other and sony are
very much pushing this is a movie that
you need to see in order to understand
how their synesthetics is formed though
we got very close to having the group in
no way home they have now finally put
their plans into full effect and unlike
the end of the amazing spider-man 2 they
now have a full slate of movies craven
the hunter is next and i'm just hoping
that marvel's studio steps in and takes
the reins before things get out of hand
because i'm not craving what they're
doing eh thank you thank you what a what
a terrific audience
i'm here a week now the film culminates
with us in the mcu's new york the sky
cracks open much like how it did at the
end of nowhere home and we go to tombs
who's glowing white in his prison cell
for some reason because he knows that
peter parker is spider-man he's getting
flung across the multiverse into sony
land even though that completely
disregards the rules set up by the spell
that's not how this spell works now when
the spell was first interrupted it
started pulling people into the mcu who
knew that peter parker was spider-man
and at the end of the movie they were
returned home after strange erased this
knowledge from everyone's mind tombs
wouldn't need to go into another
dimension because he's already home and
sony just seemed to be messing up the
rules of their own movie it begs the
question why didn't mj ned the avengers
jay jonah jameson hell the entire world
who knew gets in over there but moving
on now tombs finds himself in a
different cell and then we get a news
report which regards it as a bizarre
appearance in the prison that no one can
explain the report then says that a
hearing is being held that could lead to
his immediate release and we then see
him being escorted out of the prison
this appears to be the scene from the
trailers in which he met morbius for the
first time but like i said it was
removed now it actually would have made
sense to have been left in as it would
explain how he ends up meeting the
character in the following scene but
nope can't have our sony movies making
sense now can we now adrian is let go
because a if a ted bundy varian showed
up randomly in this universe in a prison
jumpsuit the first thing you'd want to
do is let him out of jail now from here
we jump to the second scene and we catch
morbius driving out to destination and
after reaching it the vulture swoops in
now though the director didn't say how
he got his costume he did state that
tombs is resourceful and that it's a
slightly different version from the mcu
one the wings now have bright beaming
lights on them and the mask is slightly
different rather than wearing a standard
jet pilot helmet with an oxygen mask
tomb now has a one that resembles more
of a beak he says he's unsure how he got
there but he thinks that it might have
something to do with your old friendly
neighborhood spider-man now we can't
play the scene but he's clearly as
confused as we are of the whole ordeal
therefore i think we can kind of guess
that his memory has been wiped too and
that he now no longer remembers peter
parker as the web head though strange
might have done this across the entire
multiverse and toby could be returning
home to find mj is now dating another
five people again or something now
vulture says that he's still figuring
out the universe but that a bunch of
people like them should team up and do
some quote-unquote good morbius says
it's intriguing which ends the film and
thus the birth of the sinister six
begins so yeah the guy is still figuring
out the universe but is resourceful
enough to pull together a vulture
costume it just feels like they did a
moonlight and said random [ __ ] go
because
yeah weird no now they have said that
they want to do some good and obviously
mobius is somewhat of an antihero tombs
has had a second chance and i maybe
they've changed however we do know from
the plans by sony that they will be
becoming the villains that they are in
the comics and this will of course throw
them up against spider-man now as
mentioned earlier we also know that
craven is coming around the corner and
it is possible that venom may also be
brought into the ranks this version's
eddie brock knew who spider-man was
because venom's collective symbiote
subconscious span the entire multiverse
and thus he plucked the information from
other versions of himself these have
also had vendettas against spider-man
which could potentially tip him into
seeing him as a danger now i think it's
kind of weird to do this arc with
vulture as he already somewhat redeemed
himself and the movie is just putting
him back to square one in homecoming he
of course wanted to rob tony stark
because he saw it as an injustice that
he and damage control took away his
business tombs pulled off a big job and
spider-man tried to save his life which
is pretty much why he kept his identity
secret from mcgorgon i think going
forward he will probably go on a similar
arc in not knowing who spider-man is
fighting him realizing he's a good kid
and then deciding to let the guy live he
might even die down the line and those
are the sorts of arcs i can see him
going on however for the next couple of
movies expect to see him popping up in
post-credits scenes as a nick fury type
figure recruiting villains from spidey's
rogue gallery the movie has several nods
to other spider-man characters and on
the daily bugle pages that pop up we get
mentions of black cat rhino and also
chameleon rhino of course featured in
the garfield film i think both chameleon
and black cat would be great additions
as long as they're handled correctly now
there isn't really much precedent for a
vulture and morbius team up in the
comics and typically the members of the
group tend to be more in line with what
we had in our way home it's going to be
interesting to see what they do but
there is a big chance that they're going
to [ __ ] it up now the film is a complete
mess and it's a while that we've gone
from one of the best comic book movies
in batman to one of its worst in less
than a month after seeing what sony is
bringing to the table i can completely
see why foggy got venom into the mcu
took the symbiote and then sent him back
quicker than he arrived it's clear they
don't want sony connected and
unfortunately marvel studios is stuck in
this position where they have to play
ball with the studio in order to have
their biggest name as part the mcu the
first trailer released for this movie
all the way back in january 2020 and i
think at this point that sony just
wanted the whole thing out lots of
things feel majorly underdeveloped and
you have some breakneck twists and turns
morbius turns into a vampire without
seeing any real transformation and matt
smith's turn comes completely out of the
blue the police characters have no
character development and everything
just feels like it's a trailer where
you're getting the plot points but no
depth beyond that honestly the movie
makes house of gucci look like it should
have won the oscars that it thought it
was gonna get and everything is a
misfire the story is dated the editing
is terrible and i would advise sony to
take a serious look at these films and
ask if it's worth getting in some better
talents to help to write them overall
it's just a massive misfire it sucks i
know i did that joke twice but
four out of ten four four out of ten now
and of course love to hear your thoughts
so make sure you comment below and let
me know we are in a competition right
now giving away three copies of
spider-man now at home on the 15th of
april and all you have to do to be on
the chance of winning is like the video
make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the film we
picked the comments at random at the end
of the month and the winners are the
last one on screen right now save that
to you then message me on twitter at
heavyspoilers if you want something else
to watch then make sure you check out
albright and moonlight episode 1 which
will be linked on screen right now way
better video than this way better marvel
property than this just all around
better sorry for ruining your day uh
yeah thanks for sitting until the end of
the video i'll be paul you'll be the
best and uh take care of yourself mate
we have we had a laugh with this one and
i hope you enjoyed it peace